you know in the history of our industry
there have been some real major events
that had transformed the industry and
had a huge impact in our lives the
invention of the integrated circuit
really opened up a huge number of
opportunities to do things that were
unimaginable back then then the creation
of the personal computer the PC that was
a huge impact on our lives not only in
our own personal lives but in the way
industry conducted itself and how to use
computers to do the things that were
important to them then the third thing
was the introduction of course of the
Internet I mean that internet with PCs
and integrated circuit you can see how
all that is building and and changing
the world I believe that the next step
is going to be what's called cognitive
computing because technology has changed
so much that we have not so much power
in our computing capability and so much
memory that we can store that we're able
for the first time to actually create
products that begin to mimic how our
brain works and what that means is that
the product can actually on a very
narrow particularly expertise could be
as narrow as let's say weather
forecasting for example something very
narrow that the product begins to learn
as it is used and in a way that means it
has some cognitive capability so the
more you use it the better it becomes at
a particular function to the point where
it actually gets to a point where he
begins to actually ask questions of you
think of it as a child you know when a
child is born their brain is empty
begins to get filled with stuff
hopefully mostly good but you know it
comes a point in time when the child
touches a hot plate and the mother says
hot then the child knows from then on
every time somebody says hot he better
be careful because now his program in
his brain and he's learning it continues
to learn but there comes that time in
the child's life that all of us that
have been parents either dread or look
forward to it when the child starts
asking why you know when you do
something you say why why what where the
child soon is learning he now has enough
cognitive capability
understand enough of what's going on but
not enough so he'll ask why well in the
same way these circuits get to a point
where actually they begin to query back
and say I need more information give me
more information tell me about this and
there are some experiments going today
on healthcare in oil exploration in
financial transactions where they
actually begin to tap the power of
cognitive computing and I believe that
when that happens we're gonna enter an
era that's unimaginable today and in
some ways it's kind of exciting to think
about the fact that we could surround it
by intelligence that helps us make our
lives better but it's also somewhat
frightening and the fact that you're not
surrounded by intelligence that begins
to think they know more than you do and
and but we're moving in that direction I
see it happening I think we're about 10
years away from that being a real
commercial reality however the work I've
seen done in healthcare and oil
exploration and financial transactions
tells me that this thing is it's very
real and I'll give you one small example
of how powerful it can be cannot
disclose the names of the companies but
in one particular example is they've
looked at the data on a particular
medicine that was used to you know to
treat patients and the way things have
been done up to now is you get a
medicine you get FDA approval and then
you put it out and then you collect data
and about 10 years later you say you
know what we're gonna take the medicine
off the market because it's causing some
major problem well they took an example
like that and say let's pretend that we
had this cognitive capability back then
and fitted the data that we had and see
what happens well this actually
cognitive machine was able to predict
within a matter of weeks of the product
being on the market what took ten years
of collecting data so you can see how
powerful something like that could be
and what it does is because the
computing capabilities so fast and the
amount of memory so large in a very
narrow segment it can do what let's say
10,000 people would do if you could get
a multi
to look at one problem and so it is I
see this to me as the next revolution in
technology and will impact everything
that we do